[Music]
beverly's with us beverly's in boise
idaho hi beverly how are you
hi dave
hi hi ken thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
i have a very simple question for you
how much cash is
too much cash to keep at home
and where would you put it where should
you put it since the banks are only
giving you one percent hmm
so you're a
cash under the mattress woman are you
maybe in some coffee cans buried in the
backyard
so how much cash do you want to keep at
home
well you always say pay cash for stuff
well obviously you cannot go down to the
car store and put seventy thousand
dollars of cash on their debt
so you cannot go down to the what store
the automobile store and put seventy
thousand dollars cash did you say
seventy
yeah you're buying a nice car
to buy a new car to buy a new truck
you're buying a nice truck
all right
well i i don't do that when i'm buying a
70 000 item i wire it
i i don't carry cash in now if i'm
negotiating with an individual for a
used item i might use the power of cash
like we have taught and wave it under
their nose and see if i can get a better
deal i've done that i'm not above doing
that but i don't
i i don't i don't think i'm going to
recommend beverly walks down with a
suitcase full of money like a drug
dealer to a 70 000 car purchase i'm just
going to let you wire that money in
so you would put the money in the bank
and wire it and get one percent well
you're not getting anything in the
bottom of your mattress
that's true yeah so it's it's you know i
know that it's not the one
it's i don't want you to get robbed i
don't want somebody knock you in the
head and take 70 grand out of your house
i don't have 70 grand in my house
so that's just when you say you pay cash
for stuff you keep your money in a bank
or a credit union or something and then
you wire it yeah and i wire it and
meaning i don't go into debt is what i
mean when i pay cash now i have a pocket
full of cash right now i i carry a uh
you know a money clip in my front pocket
that's usually got a thousand bucks in
it but that just because i like how i'm
a redneck i like having some money in my
pocket right you know but that's just
walking around money and if i want to
buy something or you know most of what
that wallet goes for is tips
for you know when i park a car or when
i'm uh finish up playing a game of golf
and a guy cleans my clubs you know that
kind of stuff when i come over and mow
your lawn yeah when ken comes over and
washes dishes for us we give him a
little tip and
by the way i want to point out don't
don't come to some live event and try to
take money off of dave because he's also
got something else in his in his
pocket i just i just think i should
point that out that could be a bad
scenario for something i'm trying to
take
i'm not gonna get robbed it's okay
that's okay nobody wants to rob me
but the uh i'm not really muggable i'm
just huggable but the uh uh yeah
but anyway the uh uh yeah i don't walk
around with a bunch of cash in that
regard
when i say cash is king at the beginning
of the show it doesn't mean that jesus
isn't king it means that the cat that
cash has power and paying for things
rather than going into debt to get them
is power and so um
you know i know
a few people that keep five or ten
thousand dollars cash in a little safe
in their house just in case they you
know wanted to grab a hold of a little
money for some reason or another on a
short notice and the atm was jammed up
or something then that's okay but i you
know i i don't believe in keeping
50 100 200 000
uh you're starting to get into the land
of preppers and stuff like that then and
i'm i'm not i'm not that guy and i don't
recommend that so interesting discussion
though beverly i
i have a lot of curiosity about what's
going on at your house at this point i
gotta tell you dave i part of me would
love to see beverly walk in with some
armed security with a suitcase and plop
it up on the counter and i'd like that
truck right over there
i bet you could get a discount i'll
guarantee you she can get a discount
she's awesome